انت معرض يعني القرد ياخد منك تليفونك لبس
اكله ما تضمنش الغرفه دي كانت احسن حاجه
في الغابه يعني
[موسيقى]
فجاه احنا ماشيين عادي وفجاه طلع هاجم
الست كان بياخد منها الشنطه بتاعتها وبيشد
لبسها وحتى يعني ما كانش فيه ناس من
الغابه موجودين لان كان ممر بعيد عن
القرود ما كانش فيه قرود ظاهره قدامنا
فجاه ظهر القرد وحاول بس يعني ايه قعدت
تشد معه كتير وفي الاخر سابها ومشي يا
جماعه القرد هيجي لنا
بيقولوا لك قبل ما تدخل الغابه نحاول ما
تخليش معاك نظاره شمس مثلا تليفونك ما
يكونش في ايدك يهون في جيبك ما تبينش اكل
قدامهم عشان ما تلفتش انتباههم لحاجه هم
يكونوا عايزين ياخدوه المفروض
الناس استغربت ان ازاي ده مزار سياحي وان
ازاي بيحصل كده بس في الحقيقه ان الموضوع
يعني اتوقع انها تجربه عاديه يعني اي حد
يقدر يقوم بها هي ممكن تكون غريبه ولكن
مئات الزوار بيروحوا هناك كل يوم يعني
[موسيقى]